mein name ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video was ich
eigentlich gar nicht machen wollte da
schon sehr viele gute informative videos
zu dem thema hochgeladen wurden
allerdings je mehr desto besser um was
geht's hier eigentlich geht um ein neues
urheberrechtsgesetz und zwar genauer
gesagt um den darin enthaltenen artikel
13 und der besagt folgendes internet
anbieter müssen sicherstellen dass
inhalte die von nutzern auf ihren
plattformen hochgeladen werden im
einklang mit dem urheberrecht
schneefalls die zustimmung der
rechteinhaber fehlt müssen die anbieter
die bereitstellung der fraglichen
inhalte auf ihren plattformen verhindern
maßnahmen zur erkennung des
urheberrechts und effektive content
erkennungstechnologien die angemessen
eingesetzt werden sollen
laut filter klingt erstmal gar nicht so
verheerend ist es aber der artikel zwei
webseiten betreiber alle inhalte die
hochgeladen werden auf
urheberrechtsverstöße zu prüfen und wenn
es zu einem verstoß kommen sollte nicht
mehr der user sondern die website zur
rechenschaft gezogen klingt dann sicher
erst mal mega chillig etwas strafbares
wo und youtube muss dafür den kopf
hinhalten youtube findet das allerdings
eher gar nicht schillig die haben da
verständlicherweise eher weniger bock
drauf warum machen wir dann alle einfach
keine urheberrechtsverletzung mehr
wer doch wohl einfach an sich gar keine
dumme idee allerdings werden auf
webseiten wie instagram twitter youtube
täglich millionen von inhalten
hochgeladen und das kann einfach nicht
alles angemessen auf
urheberrechtsverstöße kontrolliert
werden und da kein webseitenbetreiber
unnötig risiken eingehen will werden sie
wahrscheinlich von beginn an einfach
alles blockieren was hochgeladen wird
auch wenn da legaler content dazwischen
ist auf solche meldungen beispielsweise
können wir uns dann schon mal freuen das
einzige das ist dann beispielsweise sich
hier auf youtube noch zuschauen geben
würde wäre content von großen
medienkonzernen firmen und unternehmen
die youtube primär einfach nur als
mediathek nutzen um irgendeine neue
folge supertalent hochzuladen oder
verstehen sie spaß oder im bild
highlight oder sogar hilf mir und meine
gestrige dumme reaktion auf hilfen
einfach auch komplett gesperrt werden
jeder in europa sollen sie das recht
haben inhalte zu verändern parodien zu
erstellen und seinen eigenen kreativen
ideen im internet zu veröffentlichen
diese form der meinungsfreiheit machen
das internet einfach aus der aktuelle
gesetzesentwurf enthält allerdings keine
ausnahme für inhalte die nutzer
alltäglich erstellen oder alle die jetzt
argumentieren und sagen hey youtuber die
dazu grad videos machen ja mehrfach
angst um ihren job und nein
ihr könnt das ganze überhaupt nicht
einschätzen
davon betroffen sind nicht nur youtuber
jede form von nutzer erstellten content
soll gefiltert werden also auch wenn ihr
beispielsweise einfach einen kommentar
schreibt oder wenn ihr ein foto kostet
oder wenn jemand seine wohnung ins
internet stellt und verkaufen möchte
wenn jemand ein profil auf einer dating
website anlegt wenn jemanden lernvideos
zu bildungszwecken nutzt wenn jemand
muss hoch lebe und in verbindung mit der
cl zwischen wieder nicht mal mehr einen
link teilen was ist falsch mit den
abgeordneten die dafür gestimmt haben
unser alltägliches leben wird einfach
komplett gesperrt allerdings noch nicht
komplett am arsch es gibt nämlich einige
dinge die wir tun können ersten schreibt
eine gruppe zwar unter dieses video oder
verfasste einen tweet auf twitter oder
latein bild auf instagram hoch mit dem
hashtag save your internet und schreibe
dazu warum du gegen den artikel 13 bist
also sei es unterhaltung oder bildung
oder was auch immer zweitens teile
dieses video hier oder andere videos zu
dem thema mit deinen freunden und
informiert sie darüber was hier gerade
von der kranke scheiße abgeht und
drittens das allerwichtigste
unterzeichnet die petition die ich unten
in der beschreibung verlinkt habe so
werden leute darauf aufmerksam dass
irgendwas gehörig falsch läuft es gab
dieses jahr bereits abstimmungen zum
artikel von artikel 13 bei denen für den
upload filter entschieden wurde es gibt
jedoch noch eine finale wahl im frühjahr
2009 10
also teilt dieses video informiert euch
auch gern noch mal in der beschreibung
über die ganze sache und ich hoffe dass
wir uns auch in einigen monaten hier
noch sehen werden
[Musik]